- [Voiceover] Hey, Becca.
- [Voiceover] Hey, Kim.
- [Voiceover] All right,
so you've brought me here
to talk about Columbus, and
the origins of Columbus Day.
So, what's the deal with
Christopher Columbus?
Was he a good guy?
- [Voiceover] So that's
a great question, Kim,
and it's something that historians
and people across the United States
have argued about for over a century now,
since we started celebrating
Columbus Day, especially.
You always see a lot of op-eds
and a lot of people
arguing on Columbus Day
exactly about that question.
So, in the last video,
I discussed why Christopher Columbus
wanted to come to the New World,
and what happened when he
arrived in the Caribbean.
So in this video,
we'll talk a little bit
more about the implications
of Christopher Columbus's voyage,
and his legacy and how
it's been remembered
in the United States.
- [Voiceover] All right,
so between the good,
the bad, and the ugly
of Christopher Columbus,
please tell me that we
can have a Venn diagram.
Can we have a Venn diagram?
- [Voiceover] We can
definitely have a Venn diagram.
So I will make a Venn
diagram of the implications
or impact of Christopher
Columbus's voyage.
So this is kind of the
bad, and this is the good.
- [Voiceover] All right,
and in between we've got,
I guess, yellow.
- [Voiceover] We'll talk
about that over here.
- [Voiceover] I like
how we're talking about
kind of the impact of
Christopher Columbus,
because I think that's most important
from a historical standpoint.
Not whether or not he,
personally, was a good guy,
but whether what he did on the aggregate
has been positive or
negative for world history.
- [Voiceover] Definitely.
So, on the good side,
a lot of historians and
people in the United States
like to commemorate Christopher Columbus
for how amazing he was
at navigating the sea.
He was the first person
to cross the Atlantic,
and he did it in only five weeks.
So, he was a really amazing navigator,
and in that process he
really connected two worlds
that were otherwise completely distant,
and really, had no idea
that the other existed.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so he
didn't discover the New World,
because the people who
lived in the New World
had already discovered it,
but he did connect the
European and African worlds
with the American worlds.
- [Voiceover] Exactly, I think that's
a really good distinction to make.
He connected, but he did not discover.
And so a lot of people like to think that
something we should remember
Christopher Columbus for
is that he discovered the United States.
Again, as you can see in my last video,
he did not discover the United States,
he actually never went to North America,
and the person that we
actually have to credit that
is Leif Ericson.
And so, can you tell me a
little bit about Leif Ericson?
- [Voiceover] Leif Ericson was a
Viking navigator, that
might be all I've got,
but Vikings were a lot earlier, right?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, so the
Vikings came to North America
through what is now Alaska
400, 500 years before
Christopher Columbus.
And so they are the people
that actually "discovered"
North America despite the Native Americans
that were already there.
They were the first Europeans
to arrive in North America.
So we'll talk a little bit
more about the bad implications
of Christopher Columbus and his contact
with the New World,
and that has a lot to
do with his treatment
of the Native Americans.
So, you can see that in these
kind of two representations
of the moment of contact.
So, here would be the bad, the ugly.
And this is the kinda good.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I can see that
this painting here on the
right, it's very heroic.
- [Voiceover] He goes look very heroic.
- [Voiceover] I know, he's
even looking up into the sky
as though he's maybe making
eye contact with God.
- [Voiceover] Definitely God's up here.
The other interpretation is looking like
a lot of what historians have read
in Christopher Columbus's journal
and in these documents that
he sent back to the Spanish,
which provide evidence to show that
Christopher Columbus and his men
on the Pinta, Nina, and Santa Maria,
enslaved the native
people, mutilated them,
and sexually assaulted many native women.
So the treatment
of native people.
- [Voiceover] So he's possibly the father
of the Atlantic slave trade,
and I would say, unintentionally the cause
of a fairly significant human genocide.
An unintentional human genocide
in the form of disease
passed to Native Americans.
- [Voiceover] Definitely.
Historical records point towards
Christopher Columbus's violence
towards the native people,
but disease was really what
decimated the population,
because when the ships
arrived from Europe,
they brought weapons, but
they also brought new diseases
that the native people had
never encountered before,
and they had no immune system
to fight off these diseases.
The Taino people were
absolutely decimated.
- [Voiceover] I think it's
important to note that
no one coming from
Europe meant to do this.
This was before germ theory.
They had an idea that being in contact
with a sick person might get you sick,
but they didn't know that
we could carry immunity
to these diseases.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
That's a good segue into talking about
what would probably be center
on this little diagram,
which is the Columbian Exchange.
So, the Columbian Exchange,
you can read more about it
in the Khan Academy article
dedicated to talking about
exactly what the Columbian Exchange was,
but I'll give you a
little bit of an overview.
So, disease was really
what came from Europe
to the New World.
- [Voiceover] How about also weapons,
like firearms and horses.
- [Voiceover] Horses, definitely.
- [Voiceover] There were
no horses in the New World,
so no Native Americans ever rode horses
until the Spanish brought them over.
- [Voiceover] And that really changed
Native American culture,
because they became so
mobile with these new horses.
So, coming in from West Africa,
enslaved people were being sold
and sent on a brutal
voyage across the Atlantic,
which many of them didn't survive,
to work in the fields in the New World.
- [Voiceover] Yeah,
particularly in what we call
the Caribbean today, or the West Indies,
so the islands that were producing sugar,
like Barbados, the Dominican Republic.
- [Voiceover] And what was
coming back from the New World
to Europe was mostly gold,
as well as Native American slaves.
- [Voiceover] So, it's kind of a triangle
between Europe, and
Africa, and the Americas.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, a lot
of historians have called it
the Triangular Trade.
And so I put it in the middle because yes,
humans were transported as slaves,
that is obviously on the bad side,
but there also were new markets,
and there was this kind
of globalization of trade.
- [Voiceover] Yes, and things
that existed in the New World
that were brought back were tomatoes,
so imagine a world of Italy
where there are no tomatoes.
It was only after the
connection with the New World.
Corn, if you think about
staples of the American diet
and the diets in the world,
many things came from the Americas.
- [Voiceover] I had to draw in some corn
and tomatoes over here.
And those are definitely on the good side.
Next I'm gonna talk a little
bit more about Columbus Day,
and why we celebrate it,
and why it's become such
a contentious holiday.
Really, no other holiday
gets as much criticism.
- [Voiceover] So, when did Columbus Day
actually start being celebrated?
I'm gonna assume that
it didn't start in 1493.
- [Voiceover] That's correct,
Kim, it did not start in 1493.
It actually began on a
state level in the 1890s.
So, it had to do with Italian immigration,
these mostly Catholic Italian immigrants
coming into the United
States in the 1890s.
In the 1890s there was a very
anti-immigrant sentiment.
- [Voiceover] Yeah,
because this is a time when
you have a lot of Russian Jews
coming to the United States,
and also southern, eastern
Europeans in general
who don't speak English.
There was much more concern,
and a lot more nativism,
sort of anti-immigrant sentiment
directed to these people,
who many thought were so different
from white Protestant
Anglo-Saxon Americans
that they would never
be able to assimilate.
- [Voiceover] Exactly, so
nativism was running really high,
that's the anti-immigrant sentiment,
that was mostly held by Protestants,
white Protestants in the United States
during this time of immigration.
There were a lot of episodes of violence
against the Italian and
Catholic communities,
and one actually inspired
the first Columbus Day.
And so, in 1891 there
was a public lynching
of 11 Italian immigrants in New Orleans.
- [Voiceover] Wow, I had no idea.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, and
it's one of the largest
public lynchings in American history.
And so, in response to that,
the first ever Columbus Day was celebrated
by Italian immigrants
in New Orleans in 1892.
This was before it was a federal holiday,
this was just a celebration
of their heritage
in a moment where their heritage
was being violently uprooted.
The first president to
recommend Columbus Day
was actually Harrison in '93.
So, 1893.
What else was going on at that time, Kim?
- [Voiceover] Oh, this is
one of my favorite things.
So in 1893 Chicago celebrated
the World's Columbian Exposition,
where the United States
proclaimed loudly to the world
that they were a important
cultural and scientific nation,
so they had exhibitions of all
different types of machinery
that had been invented,
and different types of people
from all over the United States.
It was really the massive
national event of 1893.
They did this in 1893
as the 400th anniversary
of Columbus discovering America,
but he did that in 1492,
so they were a year late.
It took them an extra year
to get ready for this World's Fair.
- [Voiceover] It was a very
patriotic sort of event.
The USA rules,
and we want everyone to know about that.
And it really was convenient
to also celebrate Columbus as that time,
as to increase this patriotic morale.
So it wasn't until the New Deal
when President Franklin Delano Roosevelt
signed Columbus Day into
law as a federal holiday.
- [Voiceover] So, why did he
make it a federal holiday?
- [Voiceover] So, FDR was under
a lot of pressure from
the Knights of Columbus,
so this was this Catholic
Italian cultural organization,
and they lobbied him heavily
because they really wanted a cultural hero
for their ethnic identity.
- [Voiceover] Why are so many people
upset about Columbus Day today?
- [Voiceover] So, this sort
of anti-Columbus Day sentiment
started in the late 80s, early 90s,
when different states which had
very high Native American populations
started to realize that
we were celebrating
a man who did inflict a
lot of disease and violence
against the Native peoples
when he arrived here.
In the 90s, Hawaii,
Alaska, and South Dakota
all stopped giving people
the day off from work
for Columbus Day,
started to kind of disregard
the federal mandate of a holiday.
The significance of these three states
is that they all have very high
Native American populations.
And actually in 1992, right over here,
Berkeley, California renamed Columbus Day
to Indigenous People's Day.
And a lot of other
states have followed suit
in this kind of renaming of Columbus Day
to commemorate the native people
and the lives that were lost
during Columbus's voyage
and the colonization projects that ensued.
- [Voiceover] So, what do you think?
At the end of the day,
was Columbus a good guy
or a bad guy?
- [Voiceover] You know, Kim,
I don't think it's actually about him
as much as it is about
the long-term effects
of colonization on the
Native American population,
which were really, really terrible.
To chalk it up to Christopher Columbus,
we can definitely not celebrate him,
but there were so many
other colonization projects,
and different events that happened
throughout American history that
subordinated the Native people,
and that's really the conversation
that I wanna keep having.